is
[Music]
[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to the 31st episode of dirty
chess tricks
now if you are sicilian dragon player
then i have a good news for you
because in this video i am going to show
you one of the high profile modern trick
in the sicilian dragon main line
from the black perspective which you
definitely want to consider in your
professional feed tournaments
the opening arises after the following
model that is e4 c5
knight to f3 d6
d4 c captures d4 knight captures d4
knight to f6 attacking e4
knight to c3 defending
and now the characteristic dragon move
g6
okay there are a lot of ways we can
achieve the main line in this game white
continue first with bishop to c4 and
after bishop to g7 f3
castle on the king side bishop to e3
knight to c6
queen to d2
bishop to d7
castle on the queen side
rook to c8 and bishop to b3
so this is all pretty much known main
line for years
and here the main move is knight to e5
which has a very good idea to come on
the c4 and thus creating a piece counter
play on the queen side
and i think a lot of white players are
prepared for that
but the move which i'm going to
recommend in this video is a very tricky
one
and that goes with a topalov variation
knight captures d4
the black's big idea is after bishop
captures d4 he wants to continue with
the move b5 and get immediate counter
play on the queen side
here there are two major responses try
by the white
amongst them knight to d5 is not a good
idea by wide the simple reason is
after this move there are a couple of
exchanges will happen
let's say knight captures d5 bishop
captures g7 king captures g7
and doesn't matter whether white take
with the bishop or the pawn the most
popular choice over here is pawn
captures d5
but after a5
black is looking for the a4 and trapping
the bishop so white has to forcefully
play the move a3
and after king to g8
i think even though the engine is
suggesting that the position is roughly
balanced
i quite like black here because
black counter play is already on the way
and white's king side attack hasn't been
commenced
it is very clear that if white is
playing for the win he has to go for the
other alternative and that is h4
and launch a king side attack
immediately
well here obviously black need to
counter play on the queen side very fast
and accordingly a5 makes a lot of sense
so now again black is threatening the
move a4 and nabbing the bishop
and surprisingly enough
white should give up that piece and
continue his attack with the mu h5
but how many of your opponent knows
about this
the natural reaction here is
i should defend this bishop and thus
move a3 and a4
obviously comes into the picture and if
you check this position in online
database you will find out that this
moves has been played very often
but this is exactly what black is
looking for and this is where our tricky
business comes into the picture
by the way if you open and place h5 then
i have attached a sample game in the pgn
which describe how black should continue
and i think in the most of the lines the
worst result is at least black has a
draw in his hand
so let's consider the other replies that
is what happens if your opponent plays
moves such as a3 or a4
the first move i want to consider is a3
well this is not a good move the simple
reason is after b4
we are attacking two sports so white
response is force white has to take this
pawn and after a captures b4
and knight to d5
this is a bad version of knight to d5
because again the same transaction will
happen but this time this will only
benefit the black
so the sample line can run like this
knight captures d5 bishop captures g7
king captures g7
e catches d5
and now king to g8
and the net result is in this line black
obtained the open a file and this is
more than enough to create havoc in the
white camp
i reach this position against a 2200
rated player where my opponent continue
here with the move queen captures b4
in other words he's saying that whatever
i'm playing is a bluff and he can take
my pawn and play for the advantage
well it's not that simple and here
i continue with the move rook to b8
queen to c3 and now queen to b6 happen
so this game is a moral demonstration
what sort of danger white face
when white continue with this a3 line
okay my opponent plays the obvious move
that is h5
trying to get his attack rolling on the
king side
but i think it's too little too late
because now black has some concrete
threats with rook to eight
in this position white cannot even touch
the g6 pawn because if we foolishly take
h captures g6
then there comes rook check king to d2
queen check
king to d3
bishop jack
king to c4
and queen to c5 finished with checkmate
in four
so considering this
white has to put some defensive
resources before rook 2 8 happens
in the game my opponent decided to
continue with bishop to c4
his idea is after rook jack
king to d2 and queen check he wants to
block the check with bishop
well that's a plus side for the wide but
the overall result is
white is in the defensive mode and that
gives all the attacking prospects to the
black
[Music]
here i continue with a very simple
continuation that is rook check
and now queen captures g2 attacking the
rook
rook to d1
and after queen to g5
i think black is coming out top in all
the variation
in the game he continued with h captures
g6 and after h captures g6
he tried this cheap tactics that is rook
to h1
but this is not going to create any
problem to the black camp because after
queen captures d5 check king to c1 and
the simple move e5
not only diffuse all the white threat
but black is threatening the move rook
to e8 and get a decisive advantage
let's consider the second option
which i think is most common what you
should do against the moo a4
well exactly here our modern amazing
trick comes into the picture this has
been recently find out
and when i checked this position in
online database i found out that
there are more than 25 games played from
this position
where many title players has played from
the white perspective
this natural looking move a4 is a big
time disaster
because of the following reason
here black should take the spawn
and there are three different choices
for the white
in fact white should take this pawn
but we should see what happens if you
open and decline this and play moves
such as bishop to a2
this is a course against a candidate
master in a blitz game where i continue
with the move a3 attacking on b2
and white has to take this pawn because
if he played move such as b3 then this
bishop will not see a daylight for a
long time
so that's not a good move so in the game
my opponent decided to play b captures
a3
but after the following continuation
that is queen to c7 so my idea is to
play the move e5 and nab a piece so my
opponent decided to capture my knight i
recaptured with the pawn
and he continued with the move knight to
d5 attacking my queen no problem i
continue with the move queen to c5
attacking a3
he defended with queen to d3
but after the move f5
i think black has a dream attacking
position my opponent continues his
attack on the king's side with the move
h5
but then he has to face this move that
is bishop to a4
attacking on c2
even though black is losing an exchange
after the following continuation which
happens in the game that is knight shack
king to h8 and now my opponent grabbed
the rook
but this doesn't stop any black attack
because now indeed black is threatening
the move bishop to c2
so my opponent decided to play first h
captures g6 and after f captured g6
he defended everything with the move
bishop to b1
so at first sight it looks like white
has defended everything
and he is in exchange up
but the perception can be deceptive and
here black has this wonderful move queen
to b6
threatening queen to b2
with a great disaster for the white
after some thought my opponent played
the move king to d2
but then he has to deal with this
amazing blow
rook to c3
and white has to give up the queen
the game finished very quickly after
queen capture c3 queen check
king to d3
bishop to b5 check
queen to c4
queen to d4 jack
king to e2
and now bishop captures c4
and why should give up the more material
with the move rook to d3
but he decided to pack up the back
immediately after king to even and queen
to e3 is a checkmate
so it is very clear that white has to
take this pawn
and it doesn't matter however it takes
black will give him the same treatment
[Music]
the most popular choice over here is
knight captures a4
but i have also included bishop captures
a4 in the pgn
okay let's see what's wrong with the
move knight captures a4
well here black will continue with the
move bishop captures e4 and after bishop
captures a4 and the move rook to c4
black is pressurizing the two spots and
white cannot defend both of them
so for example bishop to b3 is forced
and now can you see the next dazzling
reply by black
well i hope you do and find this
wonderful blow
bam
so black knight is attacking the queen
and white cannot take this knight
because then rook captures d4 is a
deadly reply so white has to forcefully
continue here with queen to e3
afterwards
black will continue with
rook to d4
now again white has two choices if we
take this knight then after rook to b4
not only black is a clear pawn up
but
a4 comes with a tempo with a massive
attack on the queen side
so here
white response is forced white has to
take this rogue but after that
black has this wonderful resource that
is knight to g3
again white response is force white has
to continue with rook d to d1
because if we continue with the rook ash
to d1
then there comes bishop captures rook if
queen captures the knight to e2 and bye
bye miss queen
so it has to take with the rook
but then after knight to f5 white loses
an exchange and infect the game
so rook d to d1 is forced
and after that black will continue with
knight captures rook rook captures
knight
and now after the whole sequence
not only black emerged with an extra
pawn
but a fast attack to boot on the queen
side
once again to illustrate my point i like
to show you one of my game
where i crushed an international master
within few months
in this game i continue with queen to b8
so my simple idea is to play a4 and take
on b2 so my opponent defended with the
move queen to e4
i continue with the move d5
so neither way white can take this pawn
and amazingly enough queen has to watch
out for the move a4 and accordingly it
has the only good move that is queen to
a4
okay black continue here with queen to
e5 attacking b2
so once again he has to defend with the
move c3
but then comes rook to b8
rook to d1
so white is attacking on d5 which can be
easily protected with e6
and after king to b1
and queen to e2
[Music]
white position is in complete zhukshwang
after a long thought my opponent
continue with h5 but this is a big time
disaster
because of black's next shocking reply
before i move on i'd like you to pause
this video and find out a move
where actually white can resign the game
well i hope you find this amazing blow
boom
so not only black is sacrificing a whole
piece but threatening a mate
and white cannot take this bishop
because of the queen captures d1 as this
bishop is pin
so in the game
he continued with the move queen to a2
but now the simple move a4
and white resign as he has to move the
bishop
and then devastation happens on the b2
well i hope you enjoy and learn this
tricky mail line
not knight to e5 but knight captures d4
and goes for the move b5
where many white players doesn't know
the theory very well
and continue with the move h4
where we can launch devastation with
a5
and wins the game very
quickly well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and i'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care
you